border security obviously is important
and we need to to figure this out in a
bipartisan way we all know there's a
problem at the border the president does
Democrats do and uh we're going to try
to solve that problem consistent with
our principles let's have a robust
debate on immigration but don't hold the
issue hostage state where you are let's
work it out we have offered a plan after
nearly 3 years Democrats are finally
starting to discuss the deteriorating
situation at our northern border it
comes as the Border Town of Eagle Pass
faces an unprecedented migrant surge
with more than 4,000 migrants Crossing
there in just the past 24 hours joining
us now from his border district is Texas
Republican Congressman Tony Gonzalez he
also serves in the house Homeland
Security committee your 23rd
congressional district Congressman
covers four of the border patrol sectors
El Paso Big Ben Del Rio a little piece
of the Laredo sector so you are uniquely
positioned to talk about this when you
look at let's put it up on the screen
the Monday number that
12,600 people crossed our border
illegally on Monday and you see that the
Biden Administration is willing to talk
about this but apparently do nothing
about it what do you
say John thank you for having me you
know my board my district is uh is at
the epicenter of this border crisis no
more words no more it the time for
action is now and I will work with
anybody to solve this problem matter of
fact when I hosted the president in in
my district after the Uval school
shooting I asked the president to visit
with him and a year and a half later I
am still waiting to visit with the
president on Solutions this this is
what's happening on the ground I visited
a facility earlier today that has a max
capacity of 1,000 people in there was
nearly 6,000 I mean the numbers I've
never seen it this bad uh the the human
toil uh toil is is definitely Rising
I worry about my agents I worry about my
First Responders I worry about the
American citizens that live along the
border we feel lost we feel forgotten
and we're we're we're dealing with all
these different things right on the cusp
of having Christmas yeah yeah we're
seeing some of the pictures that you
provided us with of your recent tour of
the Border another picture I want to put
up is something that was in Bill malan's
fine reporting this immigration
appointment that was given to a migrant
who claimed Asylum confirmed appointment
for Thursday January the 23rd
2031 that's 8 years from now and and
we've got 5,000 people who are being
released into this country every day and
some of them are looking at this and
saying I'm here for eight years what
kind of signal does that send to the
hundreds of thousands millions of people
around the world who were looking at
this and saying hm is now the chance is
now the time to go to the
Border that's exactly the signal it
sends here in the Del Del Rio sector
alone there are 10 over 10,000 people
that are in uh that are in apprehended
and and there's over 4,000 coming over a
day yesterday they processed 4,000 what
does that mean that means we're on a
treadmill we're not going anywhere it's
only going to get worse Christmas is
going to be worse than today New Years
will be even worse than then it's only
getting worse the things that I've asked
for is let's surge immigration judges to
the Border let's get cases heard in days
not years and if a person does not
qualify for Asylum which is nine out of
10 of them we Deport them back to their
country of origin you do that and this
crisis comes to an end it it the time
once again the time for words is over
the time for Action is now and a big
part of that is we have to deport people
that do not qualify for Asylum and
deportation getting harder and harder
though because we're seeing people come
from China we're seeing them come from
Africa Bill maluan uh and again in his
fine reporting talked to a group of
people who came in from India I want to
put that video of him talking to them up
on the screen because something really
interesting happened as he was chatting
with them they said they came from India
some of them wanted to go to California
they said that they wanted to be here
for work and then one of them said no no
no life danger and Bill said he thought
that that was coached and we know that
you've got a one of the criteria for
entering into this country is show
incredible fear and we know that these
coyotes these cartel members who
Shepherd these migrants across the
border tell them exactly what to say so
that they have a better chance of
claiming Asylum what what did you think
of that moment I'm sure talk to Bill
about
it oh no absolutely I think it's very
real and we've seen that happen for
three years now I've been at the the
center of these border uh discussions
these negotiations on the Senate side I
just yesterday I was speaking with the
senator on some of the things that I
think we need to do in order to get this
package to a point where we can get it
passed part of it is everyone is
essentially an agreement that we need to
raise a credible fear standard but that
alone will not solve that we have to
deport people that do qualifi for
Asylum all right Congressman Tony
Gonzalez from the Texas 23rd
congressional district we always
appreciate you spending time with us we
appreciate it thank you I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis